welcome back to New rockstars
and man I stayed up way too late last
night riding this breakdown time to take
a page from Grandpa Rick's Playbook all
right just shot and chaser
Krause
cool I'm awake and ready to hit you with
all the details you might have missed
from quite possibly the scariest episode
of Rick and Morty to date night family
the title of this episode is potentially
a play on Night Gallery the 1970s horror
Anthology series hosted by the Twilight
zones Rod Sterling while the Twilight
Zone focused more on science fiction
Night Gallery was all about the
supernatural the intro credits to Rick
and Morty directly pays homage to the
Twilight Zone so it makes sense that
this foray into cinematic horror would
make a nod to Sterling's other Anthology
series writer Rob schrob actually
envisioned the episode as being sort of
like a John Carpenter movie with an
emphasis on exploring the concept that
you're an entirely different person when
you're asleep than you are when you're
awake this episode is also heavily
modeled after Jordan peels us and you
can see inspiration from the tethered
drawn by the episode's night People Like
Us the episode opens with an epigraph a
short quotation at the beginning of a
story intended to suggest its theme this
quote from T.S Eliot is fragment of
aegon written as part of an finished
Anthology play titled Sweeney's
agnostics the word aegon is Greek for
conflict or contest which is definitely
exactly what happens when the day and
night Collide this epigraph is used to
set the tone of something being amiss
during the night and plays up sleeping
to be rather Eerie we open on Beth
trying in vain to fall asleep she plays
a game called Sheep counter by the app
company snoozy there's actually a
children's game on a website called
mathgametime.com that has a similar
function and design if you really get a
hankering to play it for yourself she
gets fed up with the game and decides to
head downstairs for a couch nap an
absolutely pro move if you can't fall
asleep in bed she startled however when
her dad jump scares her with zombie
sit-ups when the Sun rises the next
morning you can hear the crow of a
rooster followed by disintegration
noises
that's actually the sound of the
horrific alarm clock designed by Rick
that we see later in the episode this
clock itself is a great example of how
Rick treats those that He deems as
lesser beings not only is this clock
absolutely ruining the feng shui of his
room but this bulky device reduces the
life of a creature to one single
function for Rick's benefit Rick treats
the Knight family in a similar manner
with their existence being boiled down
to purely a labor force for his benefit
like most great horror stories this
whole episode tussles with social
commentary pertaining to the treatment
of the working class at breakfast Rick
shows off his New Abs explaining to the
family that his night person helped him
achieve that tasty washboard he
introduces them to a device called the
somnamulator somnambulism being a
medical term for sleepwalking using a
person's blood the machine programs your
unconscious body to do tasks for you
while you sleep of course the Smith
family jumps at the chance to utilize
their very own night person when the
somnambulator Pricks Jerry's finger he
warns the others that he might faint
Rick is the only one who notices that
he's about to pass out and still chooses
to do nothing to break his fall we jump
ahead in time to March 11th several days
after the Smiths began using their
sleepy counterparts the number 11 is
significant it's a call back to Jordan
peels us which features the Bible verse
Jeremiah 11 11. it reads therefore thus
saith the Lord behold I will bring evil
upon them which they shall not be able
to escape and though they shall cry unto
me I will not hearken unto them in an
interview with NPR peel said quote my
favorite horror images are the beautiful
ones that are subverted this is why I
was drawn to the Stepford Wives and
movies like jaws and The Shining appeal
to me is that when you have something
idyllic and beautiful and sort of
perfect that's where true horror lies
this episode follows the same theme
showing the happiness the family feels a
summer learned Spanish Beth hones her
skills on the trumpet or he gets ABS to
rival his grandpa and Jerry starts a pen
pal program with night Jerry juxtaposed
against the drudgery of their nighttime
counterparts solely performing only the
most mundane tasks side quest I love
that this envelope is addressed today
Jerry under the pillow Road a wake Town
USA with the return address from night
Jerry Avenue zzzzz sleepsville USA
apparently both their day and night
personas are into Tori Amos like the
tethered from us night people have
always existed just underneath the
surface we see night summer for example
performing acts that lie deep inside of
day summer psyche like standing up to
Rick and taking charge of the family
like red she becomes their leader the
episode also reminds me a lot of
severance in this Apple TV series Luman
Industries offers a severance program
for their employees where they separate
a person's work memories from their
non-work memories essentially trapping
half of themselves in the office while
their other half roams free as night
summer does the dishes her hands get all
roughed up from scrubbing the Schmutz
off each dirty plate the next morning
night Jerry's letter to Day Jerry kindly
requests that the family rinse off their
dishes before leaving them in the sink
so that it'll be easier for night summer
of course instead of seeing this as a
pretty reasonable ask Rick totally blows
up declaring war by smearing ketchup all
over the dining room table something
we're seeing this season repeatedly
brought into focus is Rick's
stubbornness as a defining character
flaw from telling the Morty NPCs that he
loves them and Roy to dealing with the
Knight family Rick's refusal to make
small accommodations at the request of
others sets in motion resistance that
mucks up his plans Rick and Morty start
a podcast called absolutely fabulous
which Rick describes as an AB Centric
hour of fun there's actually a British
sitcom from the 90s called absolutely
fabulous but it's more about comedic
mother-daughter Dynamics than sit-ups as
a person who has to do ad reads
regularly I love their boxer Lobster ad
the name sounds like something Tommy and
I would make up for fake Rogue Theory
ads boxer Lobster seems to be a parody
of meundies who definitely have Wookie
print items on their website before
Morty Begins the ad read he says ABS
Above So Below a play on the second
verse inscribed on the Emerald Tablet a
cryptic hermetic text highly revered by
European and Islamic Alchemists long ago
and wrecked sleeping quarters he's got a
lot of stuff on the walls here we see a
vertical map of the solar system but if
you look closely the colors of the
planets don't match the ones in our real
life solar system so this might be a
different part of the Multiverse this
robot design could be a Conroy the robot
sent to watch over the Smith family by
the Galactic Federation in season 3's
rickshank Redemption next we see several
portraits of characters from season one
including Dr Xenon Bloom from Anatomy
Park a Cronenberg monster Prince nebulon
from M Night shame aliens avered off
linkler from ritzy business and up in
the right hand corner there's a Mr
meeseeks next to abradolf you can see
the equation for column's Law and just
below me seeks there's a diagram of
Rick's spaceship and the formula for
vacuum permittivity on the other side of
him you can see a prototype of Rick's
portal gun on the far wall you can also
see the Demonic alien containment box
the ghostbusters-esque Trap Rick used in
me seeks and Destroy look man nobody
wants to be mistaken for a supporter of
the Empire the easiest way to avoid that
mix-up is to let your rebel flag fly and
you can do that with epic hero Shop's
new collection spark of rebellion this
collection is full of Empire defying
designs on hats beanies and tees that'll
get you ready for Andor if you caught
the break room last week then you saw
the live unboxing of the collection and
they had some fun with it for the record
that's pronounced Rebel scum Tommy also
shut off his death stars in the death
Stardust t-shirt that features the
Empire's greatest weapon tagged with the
rebel symbol foreshadowing its
destruction this collection also has
hats and beanies with the earliest
version of the Rebel symbol embroidered
on them go check out the full collection
on Epic heroshop.com this is the
absolute best way to support the channel
and wearing the merch is the best way to
spot fans in the wild
[Music]
so make sure to wear it to Galaxy's Edge
cons and anywhere you want to show your
support for the rebels also be sure to
tag at epic hero shop and use real epic
hero to get featured on their page get
everything you need to be the stylish
nerd you know you are at epiceroshop.com
tutorix refusal to rinse the dishes the
Knight family wages war on the Smiths
first they destroy all of the dishes in
the house forcing Rick to fly to the
forbidden zone eight more maduks past
the outer rim to forge indestructible
ones actually the way that Rick's demon
buddy crafts these plates reminds me a
lot of the way Stormbreaker was created
in Infinity War night summer switches
off for Grandpa's mechanical upgrades
rendering him fully Grandpa and unable
to go Inspector Gadget on her ass as she
Force feeds him moldy disgusting scraps
major props to the Rick and Morty team
for this one this is by far the most
horrifying thing I've ever seen without
Gore this scene with the Knight family
and their glowing eyes draws their
imagery from the ghosts in John
Carpenter's 1980s horror film The Fog
after the Knight family steals their
furniture and the zombie ambulator Rick
decides to send summer undercover to
stop the device and get rid of their
sleepy doppelgangers once and for all
real quick keep that snake Jazz poster
on her bedroom wall when he barges in
blaming her for night Summer's reign of
terror Rick dresses summer in an
extremely uncomfortable sleep
deprivation suit designed to keep her
awake long enough to sabotage the song
ambulator She's Got an air horn in each
ear a pink iPod mini heavy wool sleeves
and pants one of Jerry's sweaters an
oven mitt a glove stilettos Clockwork
Orange eye tape Forks in her butt to
keep her from sitting and most
importantly do quill a sweet sweet combo
of Mountain Dew and Dayquil guaranteed
to prevent her from sleeping when summer
goes down to the basement she finds that
the Knight family has increased the
zombie ambulator's field range to 169
69. nice it seems at first that she's
able to outsmart them but by the next
morning night summer is in control she
tells Rick but your opinion means very
little to me a call back to what Rick
said to Summer all the way back in
season one's Rick potion number nine I'm
sorry summer your opinion means very
little to me even though this was said
to Cronenberg summer apparently night
Summer's original wreck must have made a
similar comment because she's held on to
it growing more and more resentment for
her daytime grandfather night summer
tricks out the family's appliances
dubbing them proxy drones making them
sentient and filling them with stabby
sleepy needles she and the drones called
a day family damonoids a play on the
word demonoi after the night family's
takeover they stopped marking the days
on the calendar with x's as they pass
opting instead to mark them with Z's
night summer Forces Day Beth to burn all
DVDs with the word day in the title so
she Burns copies of Independence Day
Groundhog Day and Ferris Bueller's Day
Off Talladega Nights is obviously safe
because that's a night movie unable to
stand laboring on behalf of their
overlords any longer day Jerry writes a
Post-It note pleading with night Jerry
to help his family side quest again damn
y'all Jerry is really coming through for
Beth and the kids this season he's come
a long way from the cowering worm that
Beth used to see him as he's actually
holding his own this season and we love
to see it as the Day family tries to
flee the house Morty trips the proxy
drone's laser which causes Rick's brand
new ship to explode dude that sucks the
little device he used to navigate
without portal jumping was in there how
are we gonna get around now I'm sorry
but that station wagon cannot make the
journey to for bojalon Prime in one
piece and mama needs some death crystals
when the family veers onto the highway
check out the bottom left corner you'll
see part of a uto truck the same toe
themed towing company that first appears
in the pilot episode and was also used
by Jerry when he moved out of the house
in season 3's Rick mincing the stone as
they Zoom through an intersection the
name of the street is Calendar Avenue
named for Rick and Morty and solar
opposites writer's production assistant
Michael Kellner they also pass a generic
soda shop and Ice Cream Parlor as well
as a motel with the punny name the Sleep
Inn later they pass a traffic sign for
an airport which is so non-descript it's
kind of hilarious an Adderall truck
crash wakes up Summer and Rick and night
death gives Day Jerry a big old boner
when she tries choking him out at the
wheel this along with last week's
episode with the bets is really driving
it home that Jerry is a kinky little sub
in the bedroom finally the cop car
summer was driving launches off the
highway and crashes into a gasoline
Factory which causes an explosion at the
dynamite Museum next door followed by an
inferno at the even more flammable dry
Leaf storage facility when day summer
accidentally impales herself on a stray
sleep needle night summer intentionally
crashes the Family's car which throws
him off a cliff after fighting intensely
half asleep and half awake the Knight
family manages to overpower everyone
except for Rick night summer concedes to
him that if he and the Day family agree
to rinse their dishes she'll call a
truce and everything will go back to
normal obviously Rick is far too Petty
to let this fight go and the Knight
family takes permanent control and who
could blame them these people didn't
even know what the sun was before night
Jerry dared to inquire as soon as
they're in charge the Knight family goes
to Bed Bath and Beyond a luau a Chinese
Aid and the Eiffel Tower they have a
marathon of all three Night at the
Museum movies and we actually see a
cartoon version of a clip from the First
Night at the Museum on screen night Beth
even rents out a concert hall to perform
her trumpet and night summer makes
amends with night Rick getting him a
world's greatest Grandpa mug
unfortunately these dudes do not know
how to live in the daytime night Beth
can't figure out how to pay the bills
night summer doesn't know day Summer's
Twitter password the bank repossessed
their bullet riddled car and night Morty
no longer has abs that you can bounce a
bowling ball off of out of money and
feeling miserable Rick decides to shoot
a revolver at the Somme ambulator which
instantly wakes the family from their
long Slumber because as soon as they're
conscious they learn that the Choco Taco
was discontinued while they slept this
is a pretty recent event and animation
takes a long time to make so it's cool
that the production team makes room for
inserting timely jokes into their
episodes before airing it reminds me of
the pandemic joke back from the story
Train episode we know that our delicious
fallen soldier the Choco Taco was taken
from us on July i-28 and seeing that the
calendar earlier in the episode had the
Smiths escape the night family on the
24th this means that the Knight family
Burns through the Smith's funds in a
matter of days I actually got to save
her one last Choco Taco with my buddy
Topher at Riot Fest last weekend and I'm
devastated to know that it was the last
time I'll ever drunkenly shove one of
those bad girls into my maw and look I'm
not saying we lose our minds and Go full
Sichuan sauce like we did back in 2017
but I am saying that all Rick and Morty
fans should peacefully organize to bring
the Choco Taco back to life follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]